Speaker 1: I want to play a clip for you of former
Trump national security adviser Michael Flynn.
He believes, or at least claims to believe that
5G mobile phone technology, mobile data technology
is going to sort of trigger or flip a switch in a
pathogen that was injected into our bodies through
the COVID vaccine. I know. That's crazy. It's
completely nuts. Let's listen to the clip. This
is a clip from what is this from? This is real.
America's real is this real America voice. This
is reawaken America presented by American faith.
And Clay Clark is interviewing Michael Flynn.
And I dare you to follow this and make sense
of it. I dare you to understand what the hell
they're talking about. Check this out.
Speaker 2: And now it has become common
knowledge that the Lippert nanoparticles
found inside the COVID 19 vaccine can
carry pathogens that can be activated with
the right frequency being sent to them. So.
Speaker 1: Okay. So if. So far,
what's being asserted, I think, is.
Lipid nanoparticles in the vaccine. Get injected
and then if they are subjected to the right
frequency. So could be a radio wave, could
be UV light or could be 5G. Then they become
activated. Okay. Let's continue.
Speaker 2: This. There's a terrifying time
to be an American. Sure. How do you process this
and what what would you encourage our listeners to
do today, sir, of I mean, number one, because this
this pathogen that you just talked about, I think
that then there's some great articles written
about how it relates to the 5G technology that
is being input basically globally. But a statement
is that because this is a good versus versus evil
time, right. One of the most consequential
periods in history to be alive. But they're
talking out loud that lipid nanoparticles in the
shots contain pathogens. Preparing for that. Here
we go. Back it up. Here we go. Here we go. We
know that Marburg is not particularly contagious,
but it has extraordinarily high rate of fatality.
Speaker 1: Now, for people who don't know about
Marburg, this is to take a break from the
insanity. Ebola is part of a group of viruses
called I believe the term is fellow viruses and
fellow. I think the root means string in Latin
and the reason that they call Ebola and Marburg
Filoviruses is because under a micro microscope
they sort of look like strings. If
you're interested in learning about
the history of Ebola and Marburg, I can highly
recommend the nonfiction book, The Hot Zone.
Very, very interesting book. Marburg is a
real thing. It's it say it's related to Ebola,
but these people don't know what
the hell they're talking about.
Speaker 2: And we know the mechanism by
which this will be released. And that is
inside of these shots that people are received,
inside the nanoparticles, the hydrogel.
There exists pathogens inside of the particles
that have not yet opened. Those pathogens are
chimeric. They include e-coli, Marburg, Ebola,
Staphylococcus and brewer's yeast, among others.
Speaker 1: Yeah, brewer's yeast. I'm my I am
actually worried because there's yeast in there.
I'm worried that my forearm is going
to turn into a beautiful pumpernickel,
and I'll have no choice to put pastrami and
mustard on it. And it's going to be horrible.
Speaker 2: You know, that upon the broadcast from
the 5G system that is now employed across the
United States and the world, for that matter,
when they broadcast an 18 gigahertz signal
for one minute, three different times.
Speaker 1: So you guys heard that, right? It's
three pulses at 18 gigahertz within
a minute. That's the that's the the
the it's almost like a morse code.
Speaker 2: As a pulse. It will cause
those living nanoparticles to swell
and release these pathogenic contents,
thereby causing a Marburg epidemic.
Speaker 1: Oh, so it's Marburg that's in my arm.
Speaker 2: She's already spent the money on.
They've already it's already done for the Marburg
epidemic for purposes of what has happened. And
now we just need the actual disaster to happen.
And there's actually worse parts to it
than that, including the 136 gene deletion.
Speaker 1: Yeah. What? This isn't even the worst
part of it. Those nanoparticles must have some
amazing batteries because my phone won't even
last two days if I don't charge it. And somehow
these particles have been dormant from the vaccine
I got a year ago and they're ready to be activated
by 5G. The logical conclusion, of course, is
that Donald Trump is also going to become a
sort of Marburg zombie. Right. Because why would
Trump do that to himself? He made the vaccines
and gave them to himself to then be turned into
a 5G Marburg zombie. This is really crazy stuff.
And does Michael Flynn believe it or has
he been pulled into some kind of vortex
where he's just around crazy people
and he has to go with it? I don't know.
And this goes from the same. This is along
the lines of the vaccines will magnetize you.
But that almost seems so quaint compared to this.
That the vaccines will magnetize you is almost
not crazy enough compared to the stuff that
they've that that they've come up with. So
strange times that we live in, for sure.
And I have to admit, since I got boosted the
crema on my espresso machine, when I pull
a shot, it is better. I have to tell you,
it is better. And I don't know if the two are
related or not, but very, very crazy stuff.